look we made merch from one of the
quotes that you guys liked so much from
one of our episodes yes yeah and right
now it's 20 off um and this is the last
time we're gonna have them in the shop
once it's gone there will be no more so
you better get on that so get yours in
time for halloween because the moon is
perfect and it says um here no matter
what phase you're always whole and this
one says the same thing too but what's
really cute about it is that all the o's
are little moons and they're in
different moon phases so it's kind of
special go check it out guys there's
only a few sizes left but your size
would probably be there if not squeeze
into one or just wear one to bed yeah
check it out at bigmoodstore.com
[Music]
listen up hey hello welcome back to big
mood listen the [ __ ] up it's halloween
this week it's halloween halloween this
week and i would like to say
we tried
care was made so acknowledge that's
amazing
today
all right
i want you to recognize it please
acknowledge it in the comments thank you
let us know who did the best job with
their costume but you can't vote for
jess because she did too good of a job
so i'm not over jess but everyone
everyone else is up for grabs what's in
my drink uh alcohol what is that oh
there's like a hole in there
there's like an amoeba in there what
happened to you
no oh oh oh sugary oh oh well oh it's
like crystallized oh it's like at the
end of the
bottle oh you ate it what are those
glasses
what if it was like ew what if it was
like leftover macaroni that was just
like stuck to the wine glass from the
dishwasher it's like a like i hand
washed it white people boba
sugar crystal
oh my god
you're drinking a disgusting yeah piece
of paper oh i got some too oh
it's from the bottle yeah does it say
anything
this is watch keeper yeah look at how
interesting this label is too oh it
doesn't look pretty cool yolo county
where that that is whack yeah
yolo
can you introduce something
okay costumes sorry let's introduce
ourselves and our costumes go ahead gina
she's steve jobs queen of hearts
[Laughter]
steve jobs queen of hearts
i forgot to bring a costume so tiff gave
me this and this and i just ran with it
so yeah we're gonna do really good with
the makeup yeah
we're gonna have a keynote presentation
at my next meeting at the throne
[Laughter]
um i would like to give a shout out to
lake avenue who sent me costumes three
years ago
i don't leave my house and i'm finally
getting to wear it so
meow
pretty little kitty yeah yeah cutie
mickey pretty pretty pretty kitty
[Laughter]
whenever you post a picture of a cat or
you dress up as cat some old gross guys
like
i love your [ __ ] yeah and then like
original yeah so original and then
you're like oh you're gross he goes i
was talking about your cat man oh you
can calm down shut up oh geez
okay the bad guy
no my dad yeah
what about you jess i am a dead punk
rocker she just took her inner soul and
i took my inner soul put on the outside
so i found i remembered that i had my
old vest this is one of the only things
i've kept with me for longer than a
decade because i'm the type of person
that throws [ __ ] away all the time so
this is from when i graduated high
school
and it was like a kind of a gutter punk
this is the newest one i have actually
because it's still clean this is like
the last one that i ever made it didn't
it didn't make any money
cool yeah i made this i have all right i
put on all of the i'm sorry i don't
i did that with my dickies jacket we
totally would have been friends
what the hell that's so cool
you didn't even do the iron on you did
like actually stitched it wait let me
see let me see
oh is it safety pins that's right safety
pinned it ah tight oh that's different
yeah i safety pinned it in and right
yeah
i sewed these little patches
this patch in this patch
um they used to sell them at like when
you when you buy them they're like two
little prongs and then you stick them in
poke it through yeah and fold it in oh i
see so yeah um
so yeah i have this i remembered i have
it barely fits me i'm like [ __ ] a fat
old lady now
my 18 year old self uh wore this all the
time and uh and i thought yeah i've been
in the mood the punk rock mood because
it's halloween yeah listening to afi and
misfits again
miss murder so good that's like kind of
old that's like later afi no one likes
that one
that's the one song i know from them but
yeah no i used to be like more hardcore
punk so i would never admit that i
listened to afi so now that i'm an adult
for the hardcore yeah yeah anyway so yes
this is me this is the inside of me even
though i don't look like this on a
normal basis but you're seeing the real
me right now oh i love you guys it's not
the most authentic you've been this is
the most authentic i've ever been in
front of people
look like a south southern girl
and then me i am tiff and i'm minnie
mouse an accidental minnie mouse yes
because i recently purchased this red
skirt which was supposed to be burgundy
but it came out pretty much pretty red
yeah it's like bright red and then i
also purchased this uh shirt it's a
maternity shirt feel it's [ __ ] soft
and then oh yeah it also stretches like
crazy and so you can get as fat as you
want yeah exactly it's like just really
comfy so anyway i purchased both of
these items they came in the same day
and i love like immediately opening my
packages sometimes when like when i
order things i'm like oh my god presents
yeah yeah exactly and so i try on
everything i'm like okay cool and fit me
and all this stuff and then i was like
well i wonder what it would look like if
i tuck it in so i tucked in my black
shirt like under this red skirt and then
i was like i started cracking up because
i'm like i look like minnie mouse so
then i pulled out my little ears and i'm
like cool i got my helmet yeah
so basically you know you can't wear
these together i know they're really
cute yeah really really really cute
kind of shirt maybe like a different
black shirt because yeah i was asking
the girls i don't know about the black
with that red i was like what do i wear
with this skirt i feel like i kind of
regret buying the skirt now because i
don't know if you're wearing a white or
a different color i put white on and it
looked like christmas oh so
we don't know where christmas is coming
up at right after halloween it's really
crazy because you just got to keep this
for your holiday outfit i know that's it
but yeah oh and then nikki let me borrow
her beautiful
yeah those are real freshwater pearls
it's really pretty thank you you look so
cute and like you look so cute little
mom
and you did so good with your makeup i'm
very impressed thanks i did it really
fast um so listen we are i'm me i am
this much wine okay that's not your
first glass empty and gina and i shared
it but i feel like i got the majority of
it i like skipped some more off the top
anyway i have a white russian jess and i
were watching videos together because
she showed up a day early at my house
because she was really scared of
thunderstorms so she had to like
reschedule her flight and come early
okay you know what why did you have to
throw the bus she
it was supposed to be thunderstorming
all day i'm like they're not going to
take off in a thing but really she just
wanted to come visit i just seriously
yeah
she's terrified she that's the thing
that's the truth she doesn't want people
to know yeah yeah yeah
i was terrified of flying with
thunderstorms coming yeah
so we had this extra night and we
watched like the history of halloween we
watched so many videos like
cause there's conflicting histories okay
the christians tell you one thing and
then other people the history channel
tells you another thing you know it's
funny
together information here how um like
defensive and pissed off the christian
anti-halloween videos are really
mad like on youtube like there's this
one girl she sounds super young too and
she's like yeah it's the devil's holiday
like how dare you and basically if you
celebrate halloween even if you don't
call it that even if you're like no i
don't celebrate halloween i celebrate
fall harvest harvest day
with my church um you're still
celebrating halloween yeah she's like
this is an affront to god
to the devil oh my god you need to love
lady it was funny watching that though
because then when we did watch more of
the historically fact-based videos they
were saying like the meaning of
but the meaning of all the things that
she's saying are so anti-god is that
like that's not how it originally yeah
was meant to be so it's like so twisted
so we did some detective work and we
want to set the record straight but also
we had drinks so we
don't know how accurate it is gonna be
yeah
but you can see the only thing take what
you want and that's all we have to give
hey
guys no don't act drunk you have a baby
in you yeah yeah yeah i could just
pretend to click that i'm literally
explicitly saying uh uh i'll pretend no
you don't even have caffeine
honestly i enjoy smelling coffee more
than drinking anyway it smells good yeah
what wasn't there a story about
halloween being something
marriage was illegal and he secretly
married people and excuse me no that's
valentine's day oh sorry
get out of here you know what is
interesting we did find queen of hearts
wants to talk about valentine's day yeah
there are some like um
marriage related activities that did
coincide but we can get to that okay
remember uh there are some of the the
couple picking or were you already
sleepy at that point oh yeah like
the apple bobbing for apples yeah yeah
and the
hazelnut thing okay anyways okay
okay i want to start with
what we could kind of decipher from how
halloween originated and the reason it's
so kind of blurry is because they had to
like
read higher gr hieroglyphics and like
found maps to like piece together what
happens this is some old-ass [ __ ] so
people are like they have different
versions but it's kind of the same so
i'm just going to tell you like the gist
of it okay
so basically it started oh excuse me
started with the celtics
celtics thank you those are my people
why do they smell it that way i don't
know they want to throw me off yeah
pronounce differently yeah but they
spell it anyway the celtics the celtics
they stole the name from the basketball
players yeah they stole it they
appropriated it what are celtics aren't
they getting it from celtics i don't
know right
now
because we're just reading maps yeah so
then why do they pronounce it celtic and
aren't they green isn't there yeah
there's an irishman
in there yeah yeah yeah
they're just saying i should be the
celtics
we're an american basketball team so
we're just going to mess up everyone's
culture okay and just expect it
that's who we are um so
it started with the celtics and a lot of
people don't know this they think the
celtics are all just one big like
organized culture there are so many
subcultures in this culture it's like
it's like people that know spanish it's
like they're not all mexican okay yeah
they've got puerto ricans you got some
durians
yeah everyone it's different types of
spanish wherever you go they were just
all a conquered people you know
so the celtics were a bunch of different
cultures but they all kind of celebrated
this one
holiday in the similar fashion and that
was salwen sawwin
yeah it's spelled sam haynes yeah my
whole life
sam dude their language is crazy to read
yeah insane we thought the people
narrating the videos were drunk at first
like and then they all kept saying saw
when so we were like okay i guess it's
always
sauwan
okay
but spelt if you're trying to google it
wait so how'd you hear about samhain you
knew your whole life
what you said your whole life you
thought it was samhain so i'm like what
did you learn about this there's a band
called samhain
all right yeah i don't know anything
about it
there you go there's the jacket yeah
um okay so sam sam
so they celebrated
no
you get out of here
queen of hearts shut the [ __ ] up
so saw when they and this season was
basically it meant summer's end yeah
okay so
summer
end of summer and day summer's end but
they believed that during this time and
i think this too
is that this time of year is when the
veil between our world and the dead
world that spirit world
is the thinnest so
spirits and otherly were other beings
could cross into our dimensions and good
ones and bad ones at this time
wormhole like a door open yeah so two
things were going on one they were
collecting the harvest from the summer
and so they didn't have a lot of beer
like a [ __ ] on a beer because they
couldn't they didn't have refrigeration
back then so they're like we have all
this leftover mead
so we just got to drink it all in this
one [ __ ] ton of beer yeah so they were
very drunk and that's probably why they
saw drunken irish want more spirits too
but
[Laughter]
so they were so they're celebrating the
harvest and then they're also kind of
welcoming their ancestors back during
this time as like a time to celebrate
back with the living again but also they
didn't like the bad spirits so some
people would dress up in masks and
masquerade themselves such as this uh
this lovely lady over here who you
wouldn't know is a lovely lady because
she's
messed up why did i wear this mask so is
it because i love demons
no it's because she didn't want them to
[ __ ] with her yeah so she was like oh if
i dress like them they'll leave me alone
yeah or i can scare them away so some
people had that tactic and then other
people had the tactic of like niced you
where they would like offer they're like
please don't harmless here take my
fruitcakes and my
irish muffin
yeah irish soda bread yeah somebody
wanted to try one of those like you know
how like in cartoons they always say
those christmas fruitcakes are always
such garbage
was pretty bomb but also i'll eat
anything i'm trash yeah so
if you're drunk i think it's good yeah
any type of cake is good so you need egg
oh wait eggnog i was like wait wrong
holiday
well the fruitcake is that holiday oh
yeah yeah okay then i wasn't wrong what
the [ __ ] happened in my brain and maybe
i am but like some of them would offer
fruitcakes so i don't i don't know okay
i know that's why i got confused okay so
they would offer cakes something these
soul cakes things from their um so like
their respective harvests little little
things um apples even they had apples i
come back from the dead
and i'm visiting my family and they give
me [ __ ] apples no i'm killing
everyone they're welcoming you to come
party they're they're people no they're
giving apples to the [ __ ] demons oh
okay they're like leave us alone demon
have this apple okay you're getting
candy yeah to make you happy you're
getting mead and beer oh i like that you
can't see it at the table they would
like set an empty seat at the table
that's a celebration and like have like
the little you know wine glass and the
plate and everything all set out kind of
like well no the demons are so angry if
you're giving them [ __ ] apples no i
don't think i don't think they're they
apples are good why are you hating on
apples yeah satan gave us apples don't
you remember the the adam and eve's
story this he gave us apples he they
like them i don't know something about
and
applesauce
away you don't like them because you're
not a demon maybe
that's the one sign that you've shown
that you're not oh my god is that why
the demon from death note loves apples
see
oh they like them they love apples throw
it uploaded
keeps the demon away yeah yeah
yeah
okay so they set the table
and they're gonna save this place
those should be like hours long yeah
there's supposed to be no drip too but
there's a lot of drips
at all i know okay so where were we oh
yeah so they're celebrating wait i had a
question yeah moved on yeah you're
talking about they wanna they have an
empty seat at the table for ghosts that
they like are their answers for their
answers
because yeah that sounds like it does
and that's where a lot of these holidays
originated okay so started with the
celtics
over here in ireland like it was
actually a big it's a big massive land
it's not just ireland it's like
a lot of the uk like a lot of europe was
this area
um and so
yeah so they're like you got pagans you
got druids there's a lot of different
groups in the video game thing what
drews are a real thing yeah they're part
of the kill tonight that's sick so
they're like the romans this is like the
tree the umbrella is the celtics but
like inside it you've got the pagans the
druids you know that
the romans came in and tried to and try
to take over
so they're all having a good time for
centuries like the celtics doing this
little festival they do celebrating the
the fall and basically there's this is
the time where it splits the the light
year and the dark year the yeah there's
like you know how summer's yeah spring
and summer is like bright and things are
growing and blossoming and then comes
the fall in the winter where things are
dying and they're dark and everything's
there's less sunlight during the day and
so this was just honoring like a change
of seasons it's like it's honoring death
but like not just death as in things die
but like the rebirth process you know
things die and then new things grow from
the death there's also like a
contemplative period like you know like
you you do a lot during the summer but
then in the winter like a lot of things
die you kind of hibernate hibernating
concentrating that's what it's called
depression yeah yeah
yeah that's why they had all the mead
you know
so uh yeah so there were some animal
sacrifices involved but it was like
mostly to keep the demons away
what was the difference between that and
like
eating a burger okay there's no
difference yeah we give him apples and
then he sacrificed some animals to
sacrifice a lamb or whatever
okay but what do they do with these
these animals do they eat them i think
they burned them yeah they burned they
gave them to the they left them out and
then whatever was left they probably
threw in the fire what are the demons
didn't want to eat i think because
they're they're really full on apples
they waste so much food yeah apples are
kind of filling there's a lot of people
oh and it was also said that like the
more you gave during this period like
the offerings that you gave some people
were kind of stingy with their gifts so
you would have bad karma in your
following harvest like if you gave more
and you offered more then you would
probably better look yeah exactly like
because they they'd grant they'd be like
oh [ __ ] they hooked us up last year
they're willing to say they will leave
their farm alone
so
that's so crazy how like the act of
offering to the dead has been around for
so long across so many cultures
yeah chinese people do it mexican people
do it it's pretty cool yeah well first
let's take a little break real quick and
talk about our sponsor because they are
what makes this show happen this is
stitch fix you guys we love stitch fix
your style isn't one size fits all it's
all about what suits your body and what
suits the moment so why not stop and
shop at a store that is personalized to
your size and style
now they are introducing stitch fix
freestyle a shop built just for you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyles
don't laugh don't laugh i know yeah look
at her creepy looks yeah
gina is being really [ __ ] creepy and
also i'm i'm like super happy about
stitch fix
whether you're looking for a brand you
love or to try a new one with stitch fix
freestyle you can shop a range of over 1
000 brands personalized to your size and
fit with styles for workouts to work
wear for lounging around the house or
for a night out stitch fix freestyle has
closed for any occasion and there's no
subscription required they offer free
shipping returns and exchanges get
started today by filling out your style
quiz at stitchfix.com
mood that's stitchfix.com to try stitch
fix freestyle
stitchfix.com
mood
hey do your teeth look like they're
throwing up gang signs
yes well i have a solution for you
can you help me your outer teeth dude i
just think it's ridiculous
that human teeth they're just like
there's a huge flaw here this teeth
falls out and it never grows back like
it's just dumb is it where you could see
our bones
oh yeah they're outside bones on the
inside have you guys seen this the x-ray
of children what their mouth yeah their
other layer of teeth about their face
anyways if you got messed up teeth i got
a solution for you buddy it's called
candid uh thousands of people have used
candid the clear comfortable removable
and practically invisible aligners help
straighten their teeth and now
they love their smile how am i doing
this drunk
i wish i had this when i was younger
because i had braces yeah braces suck
and i didn't just have normal braces i
had headgear oh [ __ ] i was getting
radios
yeah radio signals
yeah and like getting it tightened all
the time sucks and i wish i had the
clear aligners back then
you know life sucks um
your treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by the same licensed
orthodontist from start to finish and
while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontists who are experts in tooth
movement you can book an appointment at
a candid studio near you or do
everything from the comfort and
convenience of your own home the average
candid treatment is just six months and
you'll start seeing results way before
then and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces i know mine cost like
four thousand dollars yeah mine were
five
and with your aligner treatment you'll
get candid teeth whitening for free
candid can help you get the straighter
brighter smile you've always wanted
right now you can save 75
on candid starter kit go to
candidco.com mood and use code mood
that's candidco.com mood code mood take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save 75 on your starter kit
candidco.com mood code mood okay
so back to sawwin
all right so samhain started on october
31st i forgot to mention that but you
know it was like a festival so like it's
happening
this time yeah yeah all right so let's
talk about some of the other festivities
that they did because i think it's kind
of crazy that we still have a lot of the
same things like we still do kind of the
same things and this was like before
jesus this was like way long time ago
like this was like way i don't even know
how long ago but like close to the
dinosaurs probably
and we still do these so one of them
not even look at the ones
don't pop my historical cherry
okay so
one of the things they did was bobbing
for apples which you mentioned earlier i
did read it but there was a hazelnut one
huh and there was a bobbing for apples
well so there were some uh like religion
sorry like marriage things that were
kind of
i don't know why it was attached to this
we missed that part but the bobbing for
apples thing was i think way later okay
that was like more of a modern history
type of thing but the bop the bobbing
for apple sing was the men would write
their name on the apples or no the women
would write their name on the apples and
then the men of like the town or
whatever would go like bobbing for the
apples and like they would pick the one
and like that was supposed to be your
partner like that's who you were
supposed to marry or something like
crazy like that oh they did another
thing that i wanted just to do
oh yeah
they take an apple and they you know how
they peel an apple and it can go all the
way around like the peel can be one long
string thing yeah okay so they would
single people would take single women
would take the peel and they would throw
it over their shoulder and whatever
shape letter the apple peel landed in
was the initial
of the person that you were going to be
with that's fun that's yeah i was like
we need to get some apples yeah i want
to see it form a letter
no
oh so yeah they did that and then they
had a
a hazelnut or a chestnut i don't know i
think the hazelnut thing i forgot this
it was some kind of i think we're mixing
a little bit more modern things with
some of the of a tree
it's that tree and
that nut that comes these nuts
okay nikki let's move on okay and then
they would carve okay so well let's get
into how it wasn't at the romans that
wait
wait another tradition what tradition
that you may recall you or yourself
doing is the jack-o'-lantern tradition
oh yeah yes that was started with the
celtics
oh she thought you were
she thought you wanted to cheers she was
just asking
sometimes i think i have friends but
that's like something that's like
someone waving at you and then they
weren't actually waving at you okay just
take everything i thought that was very
awkward for you i hope you think about
it it was awkward for me
that's why i drink
i was just thinking how it's bad luck to
cheers an empty cup i'm like it's not
empty no hers yeah
oh
cheers
cute [ __ ] okay so the jacqueline do you
guys know how the jack-o'-lantern i
don't know justice but i don't know okay
so there's this dude named jack and
he had a job he got on a boat he had a
[ __ ]
lantern
his name was jack though before he was
jack of the land jacko lynn
no no it was just jack
get out of here minnie mouse whatever he
identifies that acceptance
this guy was very famous because one he
was kind of an [ __ ] so he was like a
drunk [ __ ] he was like that dude that
you're like oh this guy [ __ ]
he's always around like being a dick and
so like the towns people don't really
like him that much but what happened was
he was uh like tending to his farm or
something and he can't he was coming
back to his farm and the devil was there
and the devil had heard of this guy yeah
the dog was like we gotta take this guy
out this guy yeah so the devil goes and
[ __ ] goes crazy devil went down to
georgia the devil was like i gotta take
this guy to hell because he's a [ __ ]
he's a piece of [ __ ]
no no no no whoa whoa how much this was
not in georgia this is still here
what do you do you know he'd get drunk
and he'd like he'd fight people and he'd
just be a dick and like sounds like
[Laughter]
and and the devil's there and he's like
hey jack what's up it's time to go [ __ ]
we're going to hell and
we're like
wait i get it he's like yeah i suck
but can i just ask for one last request
and the devil's like okay what is it and
jack's like i can just have one more
drink like
one more drink before we go to hell just
like one last drink and then i was like
[ __ ] okay sure i'll go with you i'll
have a drink with you so they go back to
the bar
and they both have a drink they're
sitting at the bar they're both having a
drink and they uh jack finishes his
drink and devil's like all right it's
time to go and the the
bartender gives them the bill and um
jack's like hey
this is kind of weird but i know you're
in a weird [ __ ] devil um why don't you
turn yourself into a coin and pay the
bill like with yourself
this one's not the one i heard oh so
this is the one
there's
yeah there's a couple different stories
okay he tricks the devil basically yeah
so this is the one i saw so
he the devil was like that's [ __ ]
weird but okay and he turns himself into
a coin and jack's like haha he takes the
coin he puts in his pocket he's like i
got you devil you're trapped and the
devil's like ah [ __ ]
can he just like untransform himself in
your pocket yeah this story doesn't make
sense i know but he tries to double
somehow okay and so then he makes three
well that's the second time yeah so he
makes a deal with the devil and he's
like
stop making so much noise they don't
like us talking about the devil
[Applause]
okay
so he makes a deal with him he's like
hey devil i'll let you be devil again
not a coin if you let me live another
year
and i was like [ __ ] fine and so he's
like all right and he lets him out of
the pocket and devil's like i'm coming
back in here i'm gonna get you and he's
like whatever and then devil goes away
jack's like lariata being a [ __ ] dick
as always for a year and then he totally
forgets and it's been a year and he's
honestly
that's fine whatever god yeah and he
runs the devil again he's like
it's been a year that's how so the
devil's like i've come for you jack
let's go and so uh jack's like
one more request
and
that was like okay he's like can you
just give me that apple off the tree
because you know it's [ __ ] like
apples devils can't resist apples so
uh that was like okay and he goes and
gets the apple and uh jack puts a bunch
of crucifixes all around the tree he's
like i trapped you again
and the devil's so mad he got trapped
again he's like oh darn yeah yeah dude i
used to want to like just if i ever went
to hell i'm going to bang the devil
because i feel like he'd be hot but at
this point i feel like i'll just bully
you
right yeah like why are you really satan
you're that dumb yeah
and also why is there a crucifix to this
before jesus yeah whatever yeah
he just went with whatever shape he came
up with yeah
just like
whatever it's stupid but this is how it
happened and he traps the devil again
and the devil's like oh let's make
another deal so jack is like okay i'ma
let you out but
i don't ever want to go to hell like you
can't ever take me to hell and so the
devil's like [ __ ] fine i don't even
want to see your face again go away yeah
deal and so he goes to hell and
eventually jack lives his life and he
does die he is an alcoholic dick face
and he dies and then he goes to heaven
and heaven's like [ __ ] no
no
like you can't come here no hell no and
so they send him down to hell
and the devil's like oh but we made a
deal
can't come here so
so he wanders the earth so he wanders
the earth with a lantern and he's the
jack of the lantern the devil gave him
the devil
i guess yeah on halloween and i don't
know
and then there's like there's a jack and
then like he has a jack-o'-lantern head
like a pumpkin yeah and then he has a
like a robe
and he has like a lantern yeah you see a
light wandering through the night during
halloween that's the jack of the lantern
but it was like a turnip yeah so then
what they do is to make lanterns they
would they would take turnips and they
would carve a face in it because that
was like the jack or the lantern um but
then during the massive immigration when
all of the irish people came to america
um they came to america and they brought
a lot of their cultures with them but
like all these things that they do but
then they they saw when they were making
the jack of the lanterns there wasn't a
lot of turnips but there was a lot of
pumpkins and they were like oh [ __ ]
these actually work way better yeah
these like make huge faces yeah so
they started doing them with pumpkins
instead interesting that's adorable
right but basically there was a i wanted
to get to the part where i think it was
the romans that were also kind of doing
this [ __ ] but then the roman the roman
emperor decided to go with christianity
and so yeah they basically try to take
over halloween
like the catholics or whatever basically
wanted to like so then they're like oh
you all celebrate spirits on november
1st well we're going to celebrate saints
instead so it's called all saints day
now
not your spirit thing yeah well they
wanted them to join
they wanted a religion so they let them
keep somebody there so they didn't want
to suppress are you okay
yeah okay just make sure you're okay
because you're wrong oh yeah i'm okay
my tailbone is really killing me oh no
yeah all right you've been sitting too
much baby
okay so um so yeah the romans they were
like okay we want these people to
convert but we don't want to piss them
off like we'll let them keep their
culture because that's
they'll be more likely to want to
convert if we let them kind of keep
their thing that they've been doing
let's just like make it more christian
though
so instead of them celebrating like
soul like the people like spirits like
let's do they're celebrating saints
they're still dead people but they're
they're christian dead people yeah they
became saints your culture is cool and
all but make it more us like yeah yeah
right like how can we make it more us
right and so they're like all right we
still get to do the like
mask thing and like the bobbin for
apples and you know like dancing around
a fire and they're like yeah yeah just
like
celebrate saints though and they're like
oh okay that's a good deal what's since
november 1st yeah so now november 1st
it's called all saints day and november
2nd is called all souls day which i
can't remember what what that was like
why
isn't it are you talking because this
sounds just like day of the dead right
it is the casualty yeah cause that's how
the catholics kind of took it because
the spaniards were over in mexico yeah
and they brought this same type of jam
over there but they wanted to emphasize
more of like their [ __ ] i see as opposed
to like
this celtic stuff did you read anything
yeah so i've been like knowing that
we're gonna do this i'm like wait i know
nothing of my own culture and every year
i always say like i gotta research this
[ __ ] and i still didn't do a full dive
but because i some of the stuff that i
read i was like wait that sounds like
the stuff that i read yeah
um but pretty much what i did learn
about dia de los muertos day of the dead
is that on all souls day it's because
they are
um they're actually like
inviting their ancestors to come and
spend the day so that's the day that
like there's a lot of like offerings too
and it actually came from the practices
of the aztecs and so they believed that
there were different afterlives that
existed and it depended on how people
died
and so one of these afterlives the final
destination for most for those who died
of natural causes was called miktlan and
it was ruled by this one goddess who was
often represented by a skull and so then
the aztecs believed that in order to
reach michelan souls had to complete a
crazy journey and so that they would
leave offerings to help these souls
complete that journey
to get to the final destination
destination and so there were also like
several aztec holidays that involved
other um rituals to honor the deceased
but that's pretty much like what day of
the dead like all souls day is really
honoring it's just like
their ancestors and um
and like and and celebrating and it's
also it's a light-hearted day too or
it's not like the americanized version
of halloween it's like oh my gosh it's
scary it's spooky it's like soul like uh
spirits are something to be feared
but in mexican culture it's very
celebrated and it's like you get to have
fun and be joyous and you're you're just
having a grand old time with your your
ancestors and that's why there's a lot
of food involved um
is it is there anything that light and
happy because i watched the movie and i
cried my eyes
okay
dude what movie coco
angry at my family after seeing that
movie because
i was like how dare you deprive me of
this beautiful tradition in our culture
that i never knew we ever existed on
both sides of my family no one ever
celebrated dia de los muertos really no
one nothing you were living in tijuana
for the first 16 years in your life yeah
2-1 that's crazy what is this it's
ladies
[Applause]
no yeah like no one um i did spend
halloween in guadalajara how's that
so in guadalajara they call it the
fiesta
so it's like the whole month of october
there's parties and there's like a
specific region in guadalajara where
everyone goes and it's like a big old
fair there's always a ton of concerts
going on like it's just a grand big old
party it's so [ __ ] fun
and lots of food
lots of celebration lots of like
carnival rides all that stuff it's so
freaking fun and i had only ever been
able to do it once as a kid because it's
literally in october like i'm at school
during that time and then another time
when i did live in mexico that one year
when i was 15. 16 years
one year
in portland
um yeah it's just it's a lot of before
she immigrated
oh my gosh uh
ellis island
well so i mean did you guys all
celebrate halloween do you know you seem
to be like kind of blase about halloween
halloween for me was always a work event
because what i mean as a kid oh yeah i
mean as a kid it was cool like i would
go and get candies but the thing is i
never liked candy you know
what kind of kid were you i don't like
sweets i still don't
know yeah
yeah
and then i remember in my neighborhood
there was this house i was like dude
that house looks [ __ ] cool and it was
decorated oh cool but then they made
like a haunted house out of their house
and i was pissed because i walked into
their house to get candy and this
this statue that was sitting in the
garage or i mean in the driveway i was
like that's a cool statue and he [ __ ]
got up and he chased me down the street
yeah
like it's like that's her okay like it's
fun a few feet but you took it too far
oh he like went all the way down there
you [ __ ] chased me down the street
yeah he wanted to terrorize you yeah and
my mom was probably a teenager or
something yeah and my mom was losing her
[ __ ] just cracking up
it's pretty funny yeah you know like i
was six did you dress up yeah so um
apparently for my first birthday i mean
for my first halloween as a little
infant they dressed him as as a ninja
and then one oh my god isaac was a
turtle
she was close and then i was an angel
one year and then i was a belly dancer
with my mom one year
so nothing scary nothing scary you know
i didn't oh i was for some reason at
like
four years old i dem four five i don't
know i demanded to be genie from aladdin
oh
yeah i was jasmine
blue yeah yeah for some reason i didn't
want to be the princess yeah that's a
genie so that's so funny
yeah it was like this foam
fabric whatever cut out of genie's head
and my face was in his mouth and smiling
that is so cool yeah and then growing up
afterwards like um
halloween was just
parties that i had to go because okay
because you would work in it kind of
like entertainment yeah yeah i just
worked it every week or every every
halloween it was like whatever cool
and in the 20s in my 20s i had to be
like the hot girl at halloween because i
was go go dancing but the best halloween
i ever had ever
was when i went to japan and had
halloween in shibuya oh
that [ __ ] was dope because japanese
people love scary [ __ ] yeah
these make the scariest movies
oh yeah like the original the ring
yeah yeah
but like they love halloween i was like
this is an american or whatever
tradition but like they go nuts it's all
over the world actually yeah is it yeah
it really is yeah so like the streets
are packed people are dressed up i was
dressed up as a character from one punch
man an anime and it was just so much fun
i went with like my best friends and my
boyfriend at the time it was like the
best halloween yeah that sounds amazing
i would love to do that yeah
first time i got to celebrate halloween
the way i wanted to since i was like a
kid it was red that's cool i remember
always wanting to dress up like in a
[ __ ] costume
as a kid you never did no like once i
was like a teenager okay because you
were a mom
right yeah like i mean that wasn't
mainly the reason it's just that i've
always been really conservative with my
body like i don't really show it off a
lot
and but i still have always one or not
anymore but like for a long time i
wanted to have like a really sexy [ __ ]
looking costume and i just never did i
don't know like the craziest i got was
like showing my belly like me with my
devil bodysuit with like no underwear
she was hot what do you mean like all
skin like paste like using a tiny little
not pasties but like mainly skin like i
guess even something remotely close to
and then not that what nikki's wearing
is crazy it's just that yeah i
personally was crazy
it is crazy to me
don't get me kidding
her
dream
yeah and then like with the leggings and
the super
tall ass heels like high heels you
wanted your inner hoe to come out first
yeah
you never did i never did i never really
did i guess never too late it's never
too late i don't want to anymore i'm
just really i'm reflecting on what i you
should make this year this light yeah
i don't have that want anymore have you
ever been like what what have you always
kind of been like something cute i'm
always cutesy i'm always like
mainly covered [ __ ] losers yeah
always something cutesy so for me i just
i liked the [ __ ] aspect of halloween
i would always want to dress as
something funny like a joke yeah yes so
speaking of sexy
if you want to maybe instead of dress up
sexy maybe you can listen to something
sexy
because dipsy is one of our sponsors
today shout out to dipsy everyone needs
an escape but those can be hard to come
by right now enter dipsy let yourself
get lost in a world with good things
happening in the world and
in a world where good things happen
and where your pleasure is large only
price things could come into play and if
you have fantasies about a cat
dipsy is an audio app full of short sexy
stories designed to turn you on each
dipsy audio story features characters
that feel like real people in immersive
scenarios so you feel like you're right
there with them ready to bone listen to
stories about hooking up with your
hometown crush that you never made a
move on or that co-work you co-worker
you always had a little thing for or
maybe a story that puts you in bed with
someone who's telling you exactly what
they'd like to do to you
you naughty boy or girl
um they release new content every week
so there's always more to explore no
matter who or what you're into we don't
judge and if you need to wind down they
also have a wellness session stuff
sensual bedtime stories and excuse me
soundscapes to help you relax before you
drift off for our listeners dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to
dipsystories.com that's 30 days of full
access for free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash mood
slash
dipsystories.com
and
off of what nikki just said i have no
transition to this one but let's talk
about my nails yes
we finally have a nail sponsor which is
a huge thing for me as a vietnamese
person thank you
yes wow
yeah so we're talking about olive and
june here and we're all
huge fans of olive in june olive and
june has nail polish that lasts
seven plus days at mine the very first
time i did my nails with their uh
with their mani system
uh it actually lasted more than two
weeks and this is just regular nail
polish like i'm always nuts yeah i'm
used to gels lasting that long
and but i'm not a huge fan of gels
anymore because i don't like the removal
process yeah and that's why yeah it's
really damaging but that's why i'm so
obsessed with olive in june and like i
said like their entire manny system you
can achieve beautiful salon perfect
nails at home without the salon price
tag and you don't need a base coat with
this nail polish and they don't chip
either it's freaking amazing with their
mani system with olive and jun's mani
system it comes with all the tools you
need in one box it includes a nail
clipper nail file nail buffer a clean up
brush which i love it's been a freaking
game changer because i can't
like for the longest time now i'm a
little bit better but for the longest
time i couldn't paint my nails without
getting them all over my cuticles like
the polish everywhere and looks like a
five-year-old paint in my nails but with
the clean up brush it allowed me to just
like just pick up all the extra nail
polish that i got on my cuticles and
they look perfect afterwards the box is
so cute too it comes in like this cute
box and the pedicure one has a foot rest
that's so comfy yeah the petty system
that they have is amazing
um yeah and then also comes with a
polish remover pot where you just like
stick your fingers in and then it just
removes all the nail polish so it's
super easy and they they also come it
comes with the top coat and their
award-winning cuticle serum pen like a
cuticle serum pen that you just apply
with like a little sponge or sponge and
it has a serum in it yeah it's like a
spongy serum that's right buddy
yeah did you mention sure
yeah
but also in the kit though in the mini
system that they have it they also
include a patented brush handle called a
poppy that makes it super easy to paint
both of your hands like you just pop it
on top of the nail polish and then you
can
you can just paint both of your hands
and then what jess was talking about
olive and june also has these amazing
dry drops that dry your polish to the
touch in 80 seconds
dude that thing's so cool i know yeah
you don't have to wait around to your
cuticle too and like it moisturizes like
it has jojoba
oil isn't it i was really skeptical
because my family is in the nail
business and i've never even heard of
that oil thing
and i tried it i was like this thing is
so cool you don't have to wait around
yeah the thing that i hated about
regular polish is you have to wait until
it's right it could be like yeah it
could be like 45 minutes yeah so long
like do you think it's dry then you
accidentally bump your
hand how do i get this
getting beautiful salon perfect nails at
home is now a dream come true with olive
and june your new nail life is here
visit olivine.com big mood and use code
big mood for 20 off your first manny
system this is an exclusive offer you
can only get here
that's o l i v e a n d
j u n e dot com slash big mood code big
mood for twenty percent off your first
manny system olive and june.com big mood
code big mood um yes what i was saying
was i was going to the playboy mansion
when i was in my young 20s but like i've
always said i've never felt like i'm in
my young 20s i've always felt like i was
in my mid 30s and pressured to be in my
20s so at the playboy mansion parties it
was like a big deal because like they
were half events so hugh hefner only did
four of the parties per year um the rest
were all like charity events and i went
to a lot of the other parties too but
like these were exclusive like
very cool
and invite only event is the playboy
mansion's still around after you passed
away i don't think so they sold it maybe
i don't know yeah it was old and
yesterday anyway yeah i mean they would
do events there but it started getting
like after hugh hefner decided not to do
any more parties um they
like got really overcrowded with charity
events and anyway this was back in like
2007.
um so
uh the playboy mansion yeah halloween
was like one of the first ones but
i like um you're supposed to dress sexy
because it's the playboy mansion and
like they even say it's like lingerie or
less like most of the parties were
longer or less well that's less than
laundry you show up next you
they had airbrush girls walking around
but the halloween parties were the
coolest out of all of the parties like
that was like the one because like they
had just the coolest things walking
around and like
haunted house there's a tennis court but
they made it into a huge haunted house
and there were actors in there
and stuff but yeah i um the first year i
went as pikachu but it was before they
had actual pikachu outfits so i had to
like make my own out of like yellow
lingerie
and then the second year i was a sexy
broccoli
um
very sexy broccoli exactly
i had a green afro and then i had um a
sequined green
tube top and a secret green like booty
shorts and that's the most nicky thing
ever and i love it
i made a thing that said like five a day
because at the time of the grocery
stores they would have that yeah the
band around the broccoli five a day so i
made that thing to like wear on my neck
but everyone thought i was like a roller
skate person like a disco because yeah
yeah like a stock i know yeah so i was
like sexy broccoli and yeah you're so
cute and then the the last year i was uh
i was a honey badger because that was
what is wrong with you
what the [ __ ]
was that with the viral video
genie calm down
robin williams genie
i was hiring models back then and now
she's [ __ ] showing up i'm like dude
come on man like we're talking about
this last year damn it every year we go
through this [ __ ] being funny yeah it's
just like something a cat something man
now you get it right now that you're
married
well me and my cat were both dressed as
honey badgers out here so first of all
and second of all
[Applause]
yeah both of us dressed as hunting
badges honey badger um
so there was a viral video honey badgers
don't give a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that
was an assistant too wasn't it
honey badgers they would um fight snakes
but then they would get bit a bunch and
they would just go to sleep for a little
bit yeah
there's a picture of me asleep at the
playboy mansion as a honey badger and my
caption was honey badgers
they're not dead they're just they're
taking a nap and i really was asleep
like the security was like you're gonna
have to go if you don't wake up
because i couldn't stay awake past
midnight oh my gosh
i was not ever meant to be a young 20.
the nerdiest little thing ever and i
love it yeah
yes it's the cutest thing um i have a
picture of me and hugh hefner as me as a
honey badger um can you please send that
picture in so we can put it in the video
oh yeah yeah please casey he's a
he's a criminal like a jailbird but his
number his jail number is 69.69
of course it is
yeah that was fun um yeah those parties
were really fun the haunted house was
actually really scary they had like
actors like pretending to get chainsawed
in half yeah it was like kind of
traumatizing there was a grotto oh also
like i don't think this is halloween but
i walked on an orgy one time
and yeah that's to be expected i mostly
like went because the food was really
good um like they had like a private
cheese chef and he would like show you
all these different kinds of like rare
cheeses
okay
that's sexy that's where i was yeah yeah
you were at the cheesecake
i'm like okay tell me about these
cheeses you know i kind of i can't
understand why steve talks so much [ __ ]
now yeah this [ __ ] is [ __ ] weird
what about you jess would you like
halloween i was always something scary
even there's like pictures of me when i
was like five six years old like
great like gray green face as a witch
like i'm just like always something you
were like the lindsay
yeah
i don't know what that is but she would
be a vampire like in mean girls like i
watched mean girls everyone was like
bunny and she was like a vampire like a
yeah she was a zombie
yeah i don't know about that movie but
yeah i've always been something scary
definitely i mean i don't know
i don't
trick-or-treating as a kid yeah i mean
we had the normal like i there was a
time when i lived in ohio as a kid and i
remember trick-or-treating up there with
all the neighborhood kids around the
cul-de-sac and stuff and yeah i was
always fun i don't know i just i had a
normal childhood with a picture you're
just looking like this yeah it was
always like something dark like a devil
what costumes have you had since when
you were a kid yeah just all like a
witch a devil just uh
dracula just all anything that's just
scary it's always been something scary i
can't remember not being something scary
i i i want like it sucks because i feel
like halloween now no one goes
trick-or-treating people don't care
about it anymore
it was so sad last year because it was
our very first halloween as homeowners
and it was [ __ ] 20 20. but it was
cute because our actual like our little
tiny community our neighborhood kids
um well before halloween they were like
oh you guys are you guys are decorating
are you guys gonna pass out candy okay
cool we're making a list of all the
houses we're gonna hit up and we're like
okay cool so then they they would just
come by like four or five times
but yeah we actually had um like i had
like tongs out just to be like safer
like social distance and then like my
mask
and all that but it was really sad yeah
and then i remember the very first
halloween when i ever lived on my own i
had my own tiny little apartment and i
was so [ __ ] excited to be the first
time in my whole life to pass out candy
because every other year before that
like i would i would never be home or
i'd go out and trick-or-treat myself
with my cousins and it was really fun
but yeah this one year i was like okay
cool i got my candy i decorated my door
and everything not one person showed up
and it was because my apartment was like
so far back in the building
and i don't like i guess that [ __ ]
creeped out or something i don't know
like neighborhoods the kids the parents
are just like yeah apartments like we
wouldn't really trick or treat yeah
definitely not i thought it would be i
thought it would be like the genius spot
to go because you have so many homes in
one yeah yeah a lot of people that live
in apartments aren't like they're
probably like younger people that are
going to be out yeah yeah not people are
going to grow up in a condo
a condo complex and i remember thinking
that same thing because after the
neighborhoods when we were coming back
home i was like oh [ __ ] there's so many
condos in our condo complex and the
first place we went was this like young
guy and he's like oh oh
trick-or-treaters i forgot and he like
grabbed her i'm not kidding he's
grabbing an apple yeah
and he was like oh gosh i'm sorry i
don't have candy but this is probably
better for you and my mom's like don't
eat that yeah
there's razor blades yeah
there's always some sort she would like
to check for like holes in the candy
yeah to make sure there wasn't any
i remember back in the 90s the streets
used to be filled with kids
yeah it was so much fun neighborhoods
that still do that to this day and like
it's been a mission to try to find them
for isaac's childhood like to give him
rich neighborhoods right
you would think but no no not always
like there was this one year when we
went to apollo's verdes yeah that's a
rich neighborhood yeah super rich yeah
[ __ ] dead oh suppose this is the way
it is true it's not maybe people aren't
having kids they're all old people now
and all their kids are like 40. mainly
what we saw was just a whole bunch of
mansion parties but they weren't giving
out candy yeah that's so like oh this is
you know what's so sad too is uh my dad
so we bought like my parents bought our
house when i was 13. and it was like the
first time they ever owned a house and
um it was the same thing and they my dad
went to costco and bought so much candy
and he still does this every year he
buys so much candy and there's never any
trick-or-treaters and he gets so excited
he dresses up and he's like waiting by
the door like with the big bowl of candy
you guys met him today yeah
so so he like yeah he like hope he has
his like costume on and he weighs every
time every time and my mom's always like
they're not coming dear
and he's like they're gonna go i want to
go
santa barbara change costumes in the car
every like sometimes
you're just gonna have like seven
costumes
and he likes like that like he's very
proud of that it's our house that he's
there we buy
and so um one year we had two
trick-or-treaters and he was ecstatic
yeah so i'll never forget i'm going i'm
getting he always waits he's he'll wait
until like midnight like and my mom will
be like it's 11 they're not coming and
he's like i don't know maybe they might
come and like there's a huge bowl of
candy yeah everybody doing candy
um well you didn't want to cry
throughout the rest of the year
and then last year um my because my
brother had his kid my my godson and um
he was two and so like my dad was like
well i know there's at least one
trick-or-treater oh my god he's so cute
santa claus for christmas
no but my so my dad has um
a big family and he has two brothers
three sisters but one of the younger
brother is always the easter bunny on
easter every single time and it was
always weird because uncle benny was
always missing when the easter bunny was
so weird yeah isn't it benny yes he's
the bunny all three of the brothers are
[ __ ] losing it right now i'm gonna
lose my [ __ ] right now
oh my grandpa and all three boys were
named ben all of them
wow they're all mentioned i heard that
on jk news steve told that's interesting
i never thought that was weird ever
growing up until people pointed out that
that was weird imagine you're like i
thought all guys were called because
we're like he named all his kids george
all right and i was like i thought it
was a thing like there was like juniors
back then when he had a lot of juniors
so the juniors are supposed to be the
next generation though not like the
whole like
brothers and sisters
and all the boys are named ben yeah
and so they have nicknames
yeah they go by nicknames so the younger
brother goes by frank because he looks
like the kid around the corner when they
were growing up named frank what
they're wow they were raised in carson
okay
and then the oldest brother's name is
butch because
he had a huge head and he just looked
like a butch like he was just like a
bully like yeah he's butch and then my
dad's nickname is uncle jiggy somehow
what i don't know why because you're
done with it
when that song came out
thank you played it
we're gonna drive to santa barbara with
some will smith yeah i want to hang out
with this family so bad right now
and now that i have we met her we met
her dad today now that i have a face
yeah to put to the stories
i'm going trick-or-treating you know
gina was like is that the white side or
the philippines
you know
filipino i say it's dark as [ __ ] it's
because i thought the other half was
mexican um
or the other side yeah she didn't say
white side yeah i was like is that the
filipino side they're like yeah do you
know what the [ __ ] else did you think i
thought she was half mexican still no i
forgot i was like i thought she just
didn't see color
your dad's super like young vibe though
yeah he seemed that old he was 24 when
he had me so that makes sense yeah it's
only 24 years older than me which was
really weird yeah because that's like
less than half of my life no i mean like
so what's like a normal age and my dad's
thirty-three um well like you know when
you what's your name when people have
kids i guess like 28 is like the norm
for having kids 28 to 35 yeah no because
to me at 24 i'm like my mom was 22.
he could drink i couldn't drink he's not
mexican well he's filipino so that's
kind of the same thing but no i'm saying
like he was older
because you were just young yeah he
couldn't even drink at least he could
drink yeah yeah yeah yeah
he could almost rent a car well he would
have waited longer but i was like
destined to come out i was like i'm out
i'm coming mm-hmm
well he was coming and then i was oh my
god oh my god anyway
thank you so much
for joining our drunk history of
halloween we're done yeah
yeah we're done done
um leave a comment let us know what your
halloween traditions are because i will
tell you what came from the celtics and
what i did with my own halloween
traditions because like i didn't like
the only thing we really did for isaac
was just have him dress up if he wanted
to we didn't force him
and go trick-or-treating if he wanted to
i love traditions yeah i know and i
realized that we have
zero traditions in our household so i'm
like oh my gosh there's a new kid coming
that we gotta have some friends yeah
yeah it's up to us to traditions are the
[ __ ] i love them so much they've all
been falling apart like all the ones
that i have with i feel like don't exist
that's so weird yeah it's sad i like i
don't know i like need it mm-hmm well i
also think it's because like
oh well this culture this tradition came
from this and the genocide of these
people so we don't celebrate yeah
yeah yeah that's true but and then but
then you can't even make a substitution
because like but you're really
celebrating yeah that still um i don't
think there's anything really negative
all i want to do is make arts and crafts
every holiday i feel like halloween is
pretty safe based on all the videos we
watched i didn't hear any like yeah
there were some like christians
christians
they just think everything's the devil's
holiday which i don't know we i'm not
claiming to know the truth i'm just
saying that
um the celtic history is interesting and
the only reason that they think that um
okay so
really quick before we end it because
they this british historian came to
study the celtics to like figure out
this holiday and he got it wrong because
so he thought that they were worshiping
the devil that he thought they were
worshiping baphomet because they were
sacrificing a deer and like baphomet has
a horns and he's like the devil god okay
so they thought
that the
celtics were worshiping him but really
they were like
no like we know demons no we don't like
them like a direct opposite
translation
but the christians won't let it go and
so they thought they didn't think so
when was a season or a holiday they
thought it was a god they were
worshiping so they're like oh sauen
means satan and yeah and baphomet oh wow
and yeah and so jacked up she got really
distracted
it got jacked down to the lantern
you know what the best thing that ever
came out of halloween
was that what is that movie with bette
midler hogwarts pokemon
that's a great [ __ ] movie yeah you
should really watch that
by the way our black candles are durst
now durst yeah they look weird they look
really [ __ ] they both are flipping us
off yeah like i understand
okay we're done
go visit our sponsors let us let them
know that you came from us that really
helped support the show also leave us a
rating on itunes subscribe share with
your friends and follow us on instagram
so we can say hi we can be friends this
is the second time i'm pregnant during
halloween oh
that's so cute i was a cat with isaac oh
no you're a mouse
cat and mouse game all right bye guys